I secretly started to build a set of
T-Rex bones Steve's Spirit was a little
bit of a rebel he said well let me just
try it I don't care if anybody
officially says we can do this Stephan
let's just do this and I worked with him
doing the part of the lighting and
shading and rendering that was done
after hours and spaz was did most of the
early work entirely himself just so we
would just talk about it look for
references look for ideas talk about
what we're trying to do I built these
set of Bones I had to walk and I knew I
was not going to be allowed to show it
Kathleen Kennedy and Frank Marshall
coming up and I knew they were coming up
on a Monday in November of 1991. they
came walking in and I had it playing on
a monitor and the whole deal changed at
that point so the next thing was well
can we do it with a skin dinosaur tip it
didn't really know this was going on we
went down and showed it to him and they
just went nuts I think everyone's
reaction in the room was was probably
the same was like we're seeing something
you know special I mean I think that's
when Phil got the phone call and said
you know we're not doing the stop-motion
anymore that's what we're going to do
computer graphics